let's talk about the healthiest oils to use
when you're deep frying okay now the oils
that you should avoid when deep frying are the
unsaturated type because those are very unstable
and they oxidize very easily especially when you
heat them and that would be the soy oil the canola
the corn the cotton seed the sunflower seed oil
the safflower seed oil as well as the peanut oil
and so there's a certain chemical compound
that's created when you heat or fry these
unsaturated very delicate oils it's a
bit of a mouthful but it's advanced lipid
oxidation end products now and these are
compounds that have negative effects on your heart
and there's even a chance that it can increase
your risk for getting certain types of cancer
and some of the effects are more damaging
than consuming sugar there's also a study
that i included down below that demonstrated that
it can slow down autophagy which is the recycling
of all damaged proteins in the body and
your mitochondria so that's not good
all right so here are the best oils to use
when you're de-frying things coconut oil or
palm oil some people don't like to use palm oil
then great then don't use it use coconut oil
tallow that is uh fat from beef i recommend
doing the grass fed beef fat versus the grain fed
beef fat because it's going to be healthier
talo is an ingredient that we used to use
way back it's loaded with vitamin b3 niacin it's
actually it's a good fat to fry with number three
ghee not butter but ghee this is clarified butter
they filter out all the salads and they get rid
of those and you're just having this pure fat it's
a very good fat to fry with number four olive oil
now even though the olive oil does have some
unsaturated fats it seems to be okay for cooking
as long as you keep it below about 400 degrees
and avocado oil is another oil that you can
fry with that seems to be fairly stable but
these fats will not turn into this compound
and so they're more stable so they're not going to
oxidize as fast and they're going to be safer when
they're heated all right thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the u.s. hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help